We all, naturally, want to be winners. And
so, consequently, a great many countries are
designed to reward winners. These are the
countries that pay a good deal of attention
to optimising the conditions of life available
to people who win. In such lands, if one is
a winner and falls ill, the hospitals are
outstanding: The transport laid on for winners
is superlative: The housing for winners is
spacious, light and uplifting: And winner
children are educated in establishments that
resemble five star hotels: Of course, in such
lands, provisions for losers are not so quite
so comfortable. There isn’t the money left
over. So housing for Losers can be challenging:
Transport for Losers is something of a humiliation:
And the children of losers start to learn
young about their negligible status. This
could all sound worrying, but it tends not
panic us very much for one fundamental reason
related to how the human minds work. Most
of us naturally assume that we will – at
some point – become winners. You can see
this optimistic part of the brain in action
in our well-observed proclivity for playing
the lottery. Millions of us show an inclination
to believe that we will end up holding a winning
ticket – despite the daunting odds. The
chances of winning the UK lottery are one
in 14 million. This often isn’t enough to
put many of us off. If we don’t play the
lottery ourselves, we may feel a bit sorry
for people who do. We may smile at their folly
in getting statistics quite so wrong. But
in the way we vote, we may display a strikingly
similar mindset. We too may cast our votes
for political parties determined to reward
a tiny subset of winners and cast the vast
majority of losers to a less dignified end.
We would do well to study statistics.
The chances of starting a billion dollar company in the US.
The chances of earning less than $200,000 per annum in the US.
The chances of needing to depend on the state for health,
housing, transport or welfare over a lifetime, in the european countries.
In short, a degree of financial fragility
is the statistical norm; being a loser is
the norm. We are far more likely to end up
with a mediocre salary, with delicate health
and vulnerability to ill-fortune than we are
to end up robust, invulnerable winners. Yet
still we insist on creating and supporting
Winner Countries. Here are five of the world’s
top Winner Countries, countries that go out
of their way to make the consequences of winning
as pleasant as possible. In 5th place Brazil, in 4th place India , in 3rd palce China, in 2nd place the UK  and in 1st place the US
There are a few notable loser countries on our planet.
They tend not to get the limelight. Here is
the list of the world’s top Loser Countries:
5. The Netherlands 4. Germany 3. Switzerland
2. Norway 1. Denmark In Loser Countries, voters
graciously assume that they are and will remain
losers – and therefore set about trying
to make their condition as pleasant as possible.
They make sure there is a public transport
system fit for losers: Public housing fit
for losers: And public schools fit for complete
losers: In these Countries for Losers, it
can be awkward to be a winner. No one applauds
you for driving a fancy car. Money won’t
buy you schools any better than the loser
ones. You might even go to a loser hospital
of your own accord. And your taxes might be
quite high. Both Countries for Winners and
Countries for Losers have their advantages.
The question is whether we are voting for
societies that reflect our own statistical
realities. By accepting that we will almost
certainly be and remain Losers, we might be
sad no doubt, but we may also be liberated
to scheme to live in societies that make the
consequences of failing a lot less bitter.
We love bringing you these films, if you want to help us to keep bringing you thoughtful content
please consider supporting us by visiting our shop at the link on your screen now.